Ich bin heute der Diensthabende Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Bitte können Sie ein bisschen laut sprechen.
Kannst du mich nicht hören?
Jetzt gut.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ok. Aber seit ca. zwei Stunden bin ich hier.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie so lange warten müssen. Wir sind im Krankenhaus, nicht in der Notaufnahme. Es gibt viele Patienten und viel los. Aber jetzt bin ich für Sie da und kümmere mich um Ihre Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Anita Nordhaus.
Anita Nordhaus. Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, A, N, I, E, A.
Entschuldigung. A, N, I, I wie Ida, E wie Emil?
Oder?
Nein, kein E. A, N, I wie Ida, T wie Theodor und A wie Anton.
Ok.
Und dann Nordhaus. N, O, R, D, H, A, U, S.
Ok. Frau Nordhaus. Hab ich richtig ausgesprochen?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
2.2.55.
Ok. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Nordhaus?
1,68 Meter.
Und wissen Sie wie viel Sie wegen?
Circa 87,5.
Ok. Frau Nordhaus, was würdet ihr heute zu uns tun? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, seit gestern Abend habe ich sehr starken Brustschmerzen.
Brustschmerzen? Ok. Seit gestern Abend.
Wo genau sind Ihre Brustschmerzen? Könnten Sie mir zeigen?
Ja, meine Brustschmerzen sind auf dem Brust- und Hals, auf dem Magen und hinter dem Brustbein. Ganz alle.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus? Sie haben gesagt, in den Hals.
Ja.
Manchmal ein bisschen in den Rücken, aber meistens im Hals.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, gestern Abend. Meine Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten, aber ähnliche Beschwerde habe ich ca. 6 Wochen oder 2 Monate.
Ok. War das früher leichter als jetzige?
Ja, ab und zu, und leichter.
Bezüglich Ihren jetzigen Schmerzen möchte ich fragen, sind Sie dauerhaft oder verschwinden Sie seitweise oder attakenartig?
Wie können wir das beschreiben?
Die Schmerzen kommen nicht dauerhaft, sondern kommen sehr stark und dann gehen sie wieder weg.
Werden die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer oder lassen Sie nach?
Vor 6-3 Wochen wurden sie ein bisschen schlimmer.
Immer schlimmer geworden. Ok.
Frau Nordhaus, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10? Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
5, 6.
Brauchen Sie Schmerzmittel gegen Ihre Schmerzen oder könnten Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Aktuell nicht.
Haben Sie aktuell Beschwerden oder Schmerzen?
Ja, geht es jetzt.
Jetzt? Ich meine jetzt?
Ja, kein Problem. Kann ich aushalten.
Ok. Könnten Sie mir genau Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Stichend, worrend, brennend, druckend?
Meine Schmerzen sind meistens brennend.
Und die Wellenformen, wie ein Attacke, dauern ca. 1 Stunde.
1 Stunde.
Gestern Abend war ich im Düsseldorf.
Hier mit meinen Freundinnen trinken wir Altbeer und etwas gegessen.
Bratwurst, Bratkartoffeln.
Dann kamen meine Schmerzen sehr stark vor.
Heute Morgen habe ich gar nicht etwas gegessen.
Ja.
Zusammenfassung kann ich sagen, Sie haben gestern Abend draußen etwas gegessen und getrunken.
Bratkartoffeln und Bratwurst haben Sie gegessen und auch Altbeer getrunken.
Danach haben Sie diese Schmerzen bekommen.
Ja, sehr lecker. Haben Sie einmal probiert?
Nein, ich habe nicht probiert.
Aber ich habe gehört, dass es sehr lecker ist.
Einmal probieren, ja.
Vielleicht probiere ich.
Frau Nordhaus, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Zum Beispiel Körperhaltung, Bewegung oder ...
Seit ca. 2 Monaten kann ich nicht flach liegen.
Ich brauche mindestens 2 Kissen beim Schlafen.
Okay.
Und ja, ich muss fast sitzen im Schlaf.
Schlafen.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe keine Medikamente.
Mein Hasard war nicht da seit 2 Wochen im Urlaub.
Deswegen bin ich hier gekommen. Ist das richtig?
Natürlich, Sie haben eine richtige Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Ja, ohne Termin.
Kein Problem. Wir sind in der Notaufnahme.
Wenn Sie solche Beschwerden haben, können Sie einfach hierher kommen.
Frau Nordhaus, haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Luftnot oder ein enger Gefühl?
Ja, ich habe Brustschmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt, ein allgemeines Schmerzen im Oberbauch und Brust beschrieben.
Deswegen als genau und ausführlich beschrieben, habe ich danach gefragt.
Am Magen bis Hals.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden. Haben Sie Luftnot? Entschuldigung, Luftnot oder?
Luftnot? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie sich am Brustkorb verletzt?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Sodberennen, Saurengeschmack oder saures Aufstossen?
Immer, immer. Ich habe sehr, sehr viele Aufstossen.
Morgen, Mittag, Abend, egal.
Wenn ich etwas gegessen habe, kommt sofort Sodberrennung und Aufstossen. Ich rühre sie immer.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben. Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Ich bin hier für Sie da und kümmere mich um Ihre alle Beschwerden.
Frau Nordhaus, haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Schluckbeschwerden? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, gut.
Ich habe gut geschluckt, aber nach dem Essen ja.
Ja, oder während des Essens meine ich.
Und ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Heiserkeit, Globusgefühl im Hals haben?
Nein.
Okay. Und haben Sie Husten?
Manchmal, am meisten morgens früh.
Morgen früh, ja, das ist auch für mich wichtig, aber nicht in der Nacht.
Nein, in der Nacht.
Okay, das habe ich auch notiert. Sie haben gesagt, Frau Nordhaus,
haben Sie Fieber, Steilfrost, Nachtschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
So etwas habe ich nicht bemerkt. Ich habe nur sehr starke Schmerzen.
Das alles habe ich notiert und natürlich noch weitere Fragen.
Frau Nordhaus, haben Sie Herzrasen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder Erbrüchen?
Ja, nach dem Essen.
Nach dem Essen. Übelkeit und?
Nach dem Essen geht es mir ein bisschen übel, aber nicht jeden Tag. Keine Erbrüchen.
Keine Erbrüchen. Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut, aber ich habe Angst. Nach dem habe ich immer Schmerzen.
Sie haben kein Problem mit Appetit, habe ich richtig verstanden.
Ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie ihn letzterseits ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie mit Stuhlgang oder bei Wasserlassen Probleme haben, Frau Nordhaus?
Nein, ganz normal.
Beide sind normal?
Ja.
Okay. Und ich möchte wissen, ob Sie gut schlafen oder ob Sie Schwierigkeiten haben dabei?
Wenn ich spät gegessen habe, kann ich nicht so gut schlafen. Ich muss immer wieder mindestens zwei Kissen schlafen.
Aber zum Beispiel vor 6 Uhr, vor 18 Uhr, wenn ich gegessen habe, kann ich gut schlafen.
Okay.
Aber nach dem 18 Uhr, wenn ich gegessen habe, kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Okay. Wenn Sie spät gegessen haben, bekommen Sie diese Beschwerden.
Ja.
Schlafstörungen. Okay. Das habe ich auch notiert.
Frau Nordhaus, Sie sind 67 Jahre alt und ich vermute, dass Sie im Wechseljahr sind.
Schon.
Weit wann? Aber sind Sie im Wechseljahr?
Seit 12 Jahren.
Mit 18 Jahren.
Mit?
Mit 17 Jahren. Seit 17 Jahren.
Sie sind 67 Jahre alt und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie seit 12 Jahren im Wechseljahr sind.
Vor 17 Jahren.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau Nordhaus regelmäßig?
Ja. Vor 6 Monaten war ich mit meiner Frau. Das war gut.
Frau Nordhaus, gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, ich habe nur Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann?
Seit 15 Jahren, aber ich nehme mir regelmäßig meine Medikamente.
Ich frage, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Amlodipin, 10 mg.
Ja.
Einmal täglich, morgen nehme ich. Und Ramipril, 5 mg.
Ramipril, 5 mg. Okay.
Was habe ich? Okay.
Gibt es noch etwas, andere chronische Erkrankungen oder nur arterielle Erkrankungen? Bluthochdruck?
Nur Bluthochdruck.
Okay. Ist Ihr Blutdruck gut kontrolliert?
Messen Sie Blutdruckwerte regelmäßig?
130? Wann war es? Wie hoch war es?
Zum Beispiel heute Morgen war es 130 zu 80. Ist das normal oder?
130 zu 80.
Ja, je nach Ihrer Ältere ist das normal. Okay?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Frau Nothaus?
Ja, vor 30 Jahren.
Osteosynthese. Damals habe ich eine Sprunggelenkfraktur.
Sprunggelenkfraktur?
Ja, hatte ich.
Es wurde operiert?
Ja, wurde operiert.
Mit Platin?
Ja, mit Platin. Okay.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Ja, ich denke schon. Ein Jahr später war Platin erfasst.
Okay. Außer diesen Medikamenten, meine ich Amblodipin und Ramiplil,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Gar nicht.
Nicht? Okay.
Ja, Frau Nothaus, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Meine Eltern? Meine Eltern? Mein Vater ist vor einem Jahr verstorben.
Es tut mir leid für Ihren Verlust. Woran ist er verstorben? Darf ich fragen?
Speiseröhrekrebs.
Habe ich auch Krebs wie mein Vater? Mein Vater auch. Ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ja, je nach bisherigen Angaben denke ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Glaube ich nicht.
Aber wir werden natürlich einige Untersuchungen durchführen, um das abzuklären.
Ja, mein Vater auch. Ähnliche Beschwerden. So ein Brustschmerzen hinter dem Brustbein.
Und ja, Hassbereich. Ja, ich habe Angst.
Ihre Angst und Ihre Sorge kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Aber wie gesagt sollten wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann sprechen wir wieder darüber. Okay? Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Inge, was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter hatte ein Apoplex seit einem Jahr.
Sie hatte Blutsukakrankheit. Altersukakrankheit.
Bluthochdruck. Sie lebt im Moment in Altenheim.
Oh, das verstehe ich. Und alle Informationen habe ich notiert. Frau Nordhaus, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, habe ich eine Schwester.
Hat sie auch Probleme oder gesundheitliche Probleme?
Sie ist immer depressiv. Sie nimmt regelmäßig mit.
Ja, wurde das diagnostiziert.
Frau Nordhaus, darf ich fragen ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Seit ca. 30 Jahren habe ich nichts.
Okay. Ich bin nicht Rauchern.
Vorher ca. halbe Schachtel habe ich geraucht.
Es ist wirklich toll, dass Sie mit dem Rauchen aufgehört haben.
Frau Nordhaus, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, wie gesagt, täglich nach dem Abendessen ca. zwei oder drei Bier.
Gläser oder Flaschen?
Flaschen, ja.
Oh, das ist zu viel. Medizinische Sicht. Frau Nordhaus, ja, etwas zu viel, denke ich.
Vielleicht könnten Sie versuchen, das zu reduzieren.
Warum ist das gefährlich?
Ich würde sagen, medizinische Sicht ist auf jeden Fall gesundheitsärglich.
Deswegen empfehle ich dazu.
Also, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben, Frau Nordhaus?
Das hilft niemand. Warum haben Sie das Fragen?
Ja, auch Drogenkonsum ist für uns sehr wichtig.
Drogenkonsum zu wissen ist für uns sehr wichtig, weil Drogen Nebenwirkungen oder Wechselwirkungen mit anderen Medikamenten haben können.
Okay.
Ja. Und treiben Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich denke schon.
Okay. Ja.
Frau Nordhaus, sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, ich habe nur Hohleinallergie.
Wie äußert sich Ihre Allergie?
Juckreis und Holzschnupfen.
Okay. Ja, Frau Nordhaus, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Tochter und mein Mann auch.
Okay. Darf ich fragen, was Sie beruflich machen?
Ich bin Zugbegleiterin.
Zugbegleiterin.
Ja, wie mein Mann.
Okay.
Wir sind alle Familie Zugbegleiterin.
Mit Ihrem Mann. Okay, das habe ich schon.
Wie sind Sie Zugbegleiterin?
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, aber ich denke die Zugbegleiterin kann die Zugleiterin. Ist das richtig?
Ja, wir machen einen Parkour-Kontroller.
Okay, danke für Ihre Information, Frau Nordhaus. Das habe ich schon erfahren.
Frau Nordhaus, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Geduld und Ihre Offenheit.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf Reflexkrankheit.
Das bedeutet, Magensäure, wahrscheinlich wissen Sie Magensäure, Magensäure aus dem Magen in die Speiseröhre zurückfließt.
Das kann zu Entzündungen oder anderen Problemen führen.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, muss ich weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zunächst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Ihnen etwas Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Danach werde ich einen EKG schreiben, um eine Herzursache auszuschließen.
Gegebenenfalls werde ich eine Magenspiegelung veranlassen.
Wissen Sie Magenspiegelung?
Ja, habe ich einmal gehört.
Okay, ich kann gerne erklären.
Muss ich operiert werden?
Nein, ich habe das nicht gemeint, je nach jetzigen Angaben.
Aber Sie haben schon Magenspiegelung gesagt.
Das ist keine Operation, sondern ein Eingriff.
Was für ein Eingriff?
Ja, ein medizinischer Verfahren.
Damit kann man eine richtige Diagnose stellen, über die Speiseröhre, Magen oder 12-Finger-Darm.
Wir können dadurch sehr gut übersehen alle möglichen Probleme.
Und können wir einfach eine Diagnose stellen.
Ich kann auch ausführlich erklären, wenn Sie möchten.
Ja, bitte.
Es gibt einen Schlauch mit Kamera.
Und wir führen diesen Schlauch durch den Mund ein.
Danach können wir mit Hilfe dieser Kamera alle möglichen Probleme in der Speiseröhre, Magen oder 12-Finger-Darm beobachten und beurteilen.
Und auch eine Diagnose stellen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Dettl.
Und gegebenenfalls können wir auch kleine Gewerbeprobe entnehmen, um eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Wir führen diese Verfahren nach einem Betäubungsmittelverabreichung durch.
Vielen Dank, Herr Dettl.
Nach der Operation sollten Sie hier zwei Stunden bleiben.
Aber wir empfehlen Ihnen danach nicht selbst nach Hause fahren.
Nach dem Obrigen?
Ja, ich meine nach dem Eingriff. Das ist nicht eine echte Operation.
Vielen Dank.
Ja bitte. Warten Sie darauf. Ich komme gleich. Bis gleich.
Okay. Vielen Dank. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Ipek Abla, möchtest du einen Anruf machen?
Ja gerne.
Klink, klink.
Ja bitte. Dr. Doğan, aber parat?
Bitte, morgen. Ich bin Frau Müller.
Frau Riedel hat einen Hemoglobinmärte 5,88 Gramm pro Dessiniter.
8,8. Schreibt sich Riedel R-I-E-D-E-L?
Ja R-I-E-D-E-L.
Okay, das habe ich so notiert. Danke für die Informationen.
Bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberärzten weiterleiten.
Ja natürlich. Ich mache das süßlich.
Schönen Tag.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen. Ciao.
Okay. Steffi, willkommen Herr Doğan.
Woher kommen Sie Herr Doğan?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit mehr als zweieinhalb Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Frau Oberärztin.
Was haben Sie bisher in Deutschland gemacht?
Ja bisher habe ich intensiv Deutsch gelernt.
Und habe ich auch versucht in Deutschland zu integrieren.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Hospitation gemacht oder ein Praktikum gemacht?
Ich wollte gerne eine Hospitation machen.
Ich habe mehrmals darum oder mehrmals beworben.
Aber bis jetzt habe ich keine positiven Antworten bekommen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Das ist nicht einfach eine Hospitation zu finden.
Okay. Haben Sie Erfahrung oder sind Sie Facharzt?
Ja, bis ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin habe ich in der Türkei ungefähr oder mehr als zehn Jahre als Arzt gearbeitet.
Ich bin nicht praktisch Facharzt.
Aber ich habe zweijährige Pathologie und fast vierjährige innere Medizin Weiterbildung gemacht.
In der Türkei habe ich als Allgemeinarzt und Familienarzt gearbeitet.
Okay. Ja.
Sie haben viel Erfahrung.
Ja, man kann so sagen.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Frau Oberärztin.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin in der Notaufnahme aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meine Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Frau Riedel einen Hemoglobinwert von 5,8 Gramm Dessiliter hat.
Dieser Wert ist stark erniedrigt und entschiebt sich an ihr.
Okay. Was ist der normale Bereich des Hemoglobinwerts?
Je nach Geschlechts gibt es einen Unterschied.
Bei Männer muss das sein zwischen 13,5 und 13,5.
Aber bei Frauen erwarten wir den Wert zwischen 12 und 16 Gramm Dessiliter.
Gramm pro Dessiliter.
Entschuldigung. Gramm pro Dessiliter.
Welche Art von Anemia gibt es?
Ja. Je nach mittleren korpuskularen Volumen wird Anemia in der Anämie durchgeführt.
Je nach mittleren korpuskularen Volumen wird Anemia in drei Arten eingeteilt.
Normosterre, Makrosterre und Mikrosterre Anemia.
Das können wir Anämie teilen.
Welche Ursachen gibt es für Mikrosterre Anemia?
Die häufigste Ursache ist Anämie für Eisenmangel.
Verlust oder weniger Einnahme.
Wie können Sie die Anämie beurteilen? Schwerer, mittlerer oder leichter?
Das ist eine schwere Anämie. Aber ich habe diese Anämie nicht untersucht, gesehen oder kennengelernt.
Ich kenne diese Patienten nicht, deswegen kann ich kein genaues Verfahren empfehlen.
Aber dieser Wert ist stark erniedrigt. Schwerer Anämie kann ich sagen.
Wie können Sie bei schweren Anämien behandeln?
Das ist auch je nach ihrer Beschwerden und Vitalparameter.
Das können wir planen.
Aber wenn der Patient eine Anämie hat, können wir zuerst eine Elektrosydesuspension geben.
Wie kann man sagen?
Konzentration?
Konzentration, ja.
Aber so wenig wie möglich können wir verabreichen.
Um langfristige Autoimmunkomplikation zu vermeiden, sollten wir so wenig wie möglich Elektrosydkonzentration geben oder verabreichen.
Die Ursache zu behandeln ist das Wichtigste.
Und natürlich, weil es einen Eisenmangel gibt, sollten wir die Behandlung mit Eisen weiterführen.
Egal ob IV oder Orale. Eisengabe.
Was haben Sie noch für uns heute?
Wie gesagt, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Es geht um Frau Anita Nordhaus.
Sie ist 67 Jahre alt.
Sie ist am 12.12.1955 geboren.
Sie ist 1,78 Meter alt und wiegt 87,5 Kilo.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen gestern Abend plötzlich aufgetretener retro-sternaler Schmerzen.
Laut Aussage der Patienten sind die Schmerzen nach dem Essen von Bratwurst und Bratkartoffeln nach einer Stunde aufgetreten.
Momentan hat sie weniger Schmerzen.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Hals ausstrahlen.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen brennend und wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt 5 bis 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmen sich beim Hinlegen nach dem Essen.
Während sie sich beim Oberkörperhochlagerung mit zwei Kissen bessern.
Außerdem hat sie seit sechs Wochen ähnliche, aber leichtere Beschwerden.
Die Schmerzattacken haben ca. eine Stunde angedauert.
Begleitend klagt sie über Übelkeit, Sodberänen, Aufstößen, bitterer oder saurer Geschmack im Mund.
Vegetative Anamnestis gab sich schmerzbedingte Dysomnie.
Sie ist seit 17 Jahren in Mena-Pause.
Anoperationen ist eine Platenosto-Synthese vor 10 Jahren bekannt.
Die Patientin nimmt regelmäßig gegen Bluthochdruck Amlodipin und Rami-Pril ein.
Sie hat eine Polenallergie, die sich durch Pyrrhidus und Rhinitis äußert.
In der Nuxen-Anamnese berichtete sie, dass sie seit 30 Jahren nicht Raucherin ist.
Vorher oder zuvor hatte sie 15 Jahre 10 Zigaretten täglich geraucht.
Was spricht 7,5 Päckjahres.
Sie trinkt zwei Flaschen Altbeer täglich.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Oesophagus carcinom beim Vater, an dem er verstorben ist,
Apoplex, Diabetes mellitus type 2 und auch arterielle Hypertonie bei der Mutter sowie Depression bei der Schwester.
Sozialanamnistisch ist sie Zugbegleiterin, verheiratet, lebt mit ihrem Mann und hat eine Tochter.
Nach dem Anamnistischen angaben, habe ich den Verdacht auf eine gastro-ösephagiale Gleftüchskrankheit.
Dafür sprechen die attackenartigen, brennenden, in den Hals ausgetralenden, retro-sternalen Schmerzen,
sauer Geschmack, saures Ausstoßen, beim Hinlegen Verschlimmerung im Gegensatz zu Oberkörperhochlagerung, Verbesserung.
Diese sprechen dafür.
Welchen Risikofaktor hat der Patient für gastro-ösephagiale Strecken?
Der Patient ist übergewicht, trinkt viel Alkohol, Lebensgewohnheiten sind auch übergewicht.
Für diese Patientin oder auch allgemein?
Ja, diese Patientin.
Auch sie nimmt Amlodipin ein. Amlodipin kann auch dazu führen.
Was ist die Lebensgewohnheit der Patienten?
Was isst sie gerne?
Wie gesagt, die Lebensgewohnheiten, Trinken Alkohol und nach dem Essen, oder fettiges Essen, nach dem Essen zu liegen oder später essen.
Kann sein, später.
Ja, Essengewohnheit.
Ich meine, fettiges und gebratenes Essen zu konsumieren, auf sehr spätes Abendessen zu essen.
Ich wollte danach ausführlich fragen, weil es Zeit und Druck gibt.
Habe ich damit aufgehört, deswegen möchte ich nicht diese betroffenen oder bezüglichen Schwerden beschweren sagen.
Die Differenzdiagnostik kommt aus akutes Corona-Syndrom und wegen der familiären Disposition und auch wegen der familiären Anamnese oder aufgrund der Familienanamnese,
die Ösophagus carcinoma betrachtet.
Aber der Patient, die Brustschmerzen, begleitet, gibt es keine Atemnot oder belastungsabhängige Brustschmerzen.
Deswegen kann ich mit einer ruhigen EKG diese Differenzdiagnose ausschließen.
Obwohl die Familienanamnese auffällig ist, kann ich auch ausschließen, weil der Patient keine Schleusbeschwerden und auch keine Gewichtsverlust hat.
Kann ich diese Differenzdiagnose auch einfach ausschließen.
Ist es notwendig diese Informationen hier zu erwähnen oder muss ich die Fragen oder muss ich auf die Fragen warten?
Wenn Sie Fragen bekommen, können Sie ausführlich erklären, aber normalerweise sollen Sie nicht.
Ok, danke. Und um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Aber bei diesem Fall kann die körperliche Untersuchung unaufwällig sein.
Anschließend werde ich Vitalparameter überwachen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Als wichtiges Verfahren sollte wie gesagt ein EKG geschrieben werden, um mögliche Herzursachen auszuschließen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Leber- und Niergarnwerte, Elektrolyte, Blutzucker, Lipidprofil und auch fekelle-okkulte Bluttests und auch TM Marker kontrollieren lassen.
Auch natürlich Herz-Enzyme muss ich kontrollieren.
Wie kann man sagen? TM Marker kann man sagen.
Ich meine, Karsin-Ambryonologik Antigen und Kanserantigen vielleicht 7 oder 8 oder vielleicht nicht notwendig.
Normalerweise wenn ich meine Falle vorstelle, vermeide ich TM Markers.
In Notaufnahme glaube ich.
Kann man nicht kontrollieren lassen.
Ich notiere.
Darüber hinaus werde ich Sonneabdomen durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie veranlassen.
In Deutschland veranlassen oder natürlich nicht durchführen, immer veranlassen für Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie.
Möchten Sie ZUERS Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie veranlassen oder pH-Metri?
Nein, in der Regel ja.
Diese Beschwerden oder diese Symptome schiebbrechen für eine Reflexkrankheit.
ZUERS ist es nicht erforderlich Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie oder Langzeit-PH-Metri durchzuführen.
Aber weil der Patient alt ist und die Familie Anamnese auffällig ist, würde ich gerne bei dieser Patientin Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie veranlassen.
Aber die pH-Metri ist, ich denke, ein selten durchführendes Verfahren, um eine Gasoesophage-Reflexkrankheit zu diagnostizieren.
Aus diesem Grund würde ich nicht erstmalig diese Verfahren nicht Priorität geben.
Sie sollen Ihre Erklärung ein bisschen anders machen.
Ich werde eine Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie veranlassen, gegebenenfalls Langzeit-PH-Metri.
Ich habe verstanden, als Sie Ihre weitere Diagnostik erklärt haben,
Sie sollen auf jeden Fall eine Langzeit-PH-Metri durchführen, dann gegebenenfalls Ösefagastrodo-Dendoskopie.
Ich wollte sagen, dass die Langzeit-PH-Metri ein selten durchführendes Verfahren ist.
Deswegen finde ich es nicht erforderlich, aber ich konnte es nicht erklären.
Sie haben sehr gut erklärt.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, als Sie Ihre Diagnostik erklärt haben,
Sie sollen eine Langzeit-PH-Metri durchführen, dann geben Sie einen Langzeit-PH-Metri durchführen.
Okay, das habe ich jetzt verstanden. Ich muss die Reihenfolge verändern.
Okay, weiter.
Natürlich werde ich ein Gastro... Aber das ist auch gegebenenfalls für diesen Fall.
Gegebenenfalls werde ich gastroenterologisches Konzil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Ich empfehle den Patienten, den Lebensstil zu ändern.
Das ist das Wichtigste. Und auch andere Maßnahmen,
ähnlich wie Lebensstiländerung, Gewichtsabzunehmen,
Magenschönende Ernährung zu beachten und Engekleidung zu vermeiden.
Und möglichst früh Abendessen zu achten.
Ich würde Medikamente von Prothema und Antaizide verordnen.
Natürlich ist es sehr wichtig, Alkoholkarin zu diesen Patienten zu empfehlen.
Und auch gegebenenfalls kann die Elkobaktori-Pleori-Erradiation vielleicht erforderlich sein.
Je nach dem Schnelltest oder Biopsie-Ergebnisse.
Okay, vielen Dank für Ihre Vorstellung. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Danke.
Ich glaube, dass es heute Ibrahim abe machen wird, oder?
Ja, ich glaube so.
Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Lass uns die Schrauben aufschneiden, Ibrahim.
Heute nicht.
Du bist heute zu Hause. Bitte.
Nein, heute nicht. Dann werden wir bereit.
Der Stimme des Abes ist die Stimme des Abes.
Ich habe zwei.
Ich hoffe, es geht weiter. Heute nicht.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Akınar. Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten gesehen.
Bevor ich das mache, möchte ich Ihnen noch etwas wichtiges berichten. Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor erhalten.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Frau Riedel einen Hemoglobinwert von 5,88 Gramm pro Dessiliter hat.
Dieser Wert ist eine starke Anämie.
Und jetzt möchte ich andere Patienten vorstellen.
Aber Sie können sagen, dieser Wert ist stark erniedrig und entspricht einer Anämie.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich erniedrigt und entspricht einer Anämie.
Eine Anämie.
Danke schön.
Jetzt möchte ich andere Patienten vorstellen. Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Die andere Patientin ist Frau Anita Nordhaus.
Sie ist 87 Jahre alt.
Sie ist geboren am 2.2.1955.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und wiegt 87,5 Kilo.
Frau Nordhaus stellt sich wegen gestern Abend bestehender plötzlich aufgetretenen Brustmärzen.
Wie viele Patienten?
Wie viele?
Normalerweise ist dieser Patient, der hier gesagt hat, aber um ihn zu verhindern,
momentan keine Brustmärzen.
Also keine Brustmärzen.
Dieser Patient hat gesagt, dass er so ist.
Er hat gesagt, dass es keine Vakade gibt, aber es gibt eine Chetin-Abi-Kontrolle.
Ja, Ekrem-Abi hat gesagt, dass es eine gibt.
Aber es gibt keine?
Normalerweise ist dieser Patient gestern Abend nur noch ein bisschen schmerzhaft.
Momentan ist es nicht.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es keine Brustmärzen gibt.
Dann werde ich nicht Zeit sagen.
In diesem Fall könnt ihr das als akut aufgetretene sagen.
Ich habe es heute geschrieben.
Ich wollte das für die Wahrheit sagen.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Dann werden wir das verstellen.
Wenn es nicht momentan gibt, muss ich nicht Zeit sagen.
Danke, dass ich das in der Kopfschritte gemacht habe.
Dann sagen wir so.
Frau Nordhaus, kommt heute zu uns.
Wegen akutes Brustmärzen gestern Abend.
Gestern Abend akut aufgetretene Brustmärzen.
Laut der Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Als verstärkende Faktoren ist Flachliegen und linderte Faktoren ist Sitzen.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 bis 6 von 10.
Auf der NRS.
Im Verlauf der Zeit berichtet die Patienten über ihre Schmerzen.
Schlimmer berichtet die Patienten, dass die Schmerzen seit zwei Wochen schlimmer geworden sind.
Sie haben seit zwei Monaten ein ähnliches Schmerz.
Aber früher war es leichter.
Patienten berichten, dass ihre Schmerzen in den Hals ausgetreten sind.
Nein, nicht ausgetreten.
Sie berichten, dass die Schmerzen in den Hals ausgetreten sind.
Als Schmerzcharakter erwähnt die Patienten als Brennens und Wellen für mich.
Vegetative Analyse ist anerfällig bis auf Begleitung.
Sie begleiten, klagt sie über, sauber ausstoßen, gelegentlich hüsten, überall nach dem Essen.
Vegetative Analyse ist unerfällig, mal seit bedingter Schlafstörungen, besonders nach dem Essen.
Vegetative Analyse ist unerfällig bis auf mal seit bedingter Schlafstörungen, besonders nach dem Essen.
Beide Erkrankungen erwähnt sie eine Arteriellhypertronik seit 15 Jahren.
Medikamentos nimmt sie ammolidipin 15 mg einmal morgens, Ramepli 10 mg, eine Tablette.
Sie ist unter Kontrolle. Die letzte Messung war 130 zu 80 mm Quark-Silbersäule.
In der operativen Analyse gibt es Patienten Osteosynthese und Plattenentfernung seit 13 Jahren.
Sie ist anerfällig durch Rhinokonjunktivität.
In der noch anderen Analyse ist sie nicht rauchend seit 30 Jahren, aber früher, ungefähr 15 Jahre, halbe Jahr.
Sie trinkt täglich zwei bis drei Flaschen Bier und ist sozialanalystisch verheiratet.
Ihr Vater hat eine Speiseröhre Krebs und ist verstorben an Oesophagus-Karzinom.
Ihr Mutter hat Apoplex seit einigen Jahren, Typ 2 Diabetes, Meliothus und Arteriellhypertronik.
Ihr Schwester hat eine Herzdepression.
Aufgrund der anamestischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf Oesophage-Reflexkrankheit.
Dafür sprechen malzeitenbedingte Brustschmerzen, Übelkeit, Rotbrennen, Saueraustoßen und Lebensgewohnheiten, zum Beispiel fettiges Essen und Trinken, Alkohol.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnosen zu bestätigen, würde ich meine Patienten körperlich untersuchen, danach Blut abnehmen.
Ich würde die Ambulanz behandeln und die Patientenschulung, Protonpump, Hema, Antacida, Gewicht reduzieren oder Diets-Programme planen.
Ich würde meine Patienten körperlich untersuchen, danach Blut abnehmen.
Ich habe viele Fragen zu den letzten Anamnesen gestellt.